we have minds that are programmed by
culture that can be completely at odds
with our genomes and it leads to
misunderstandings of evolution like the
idea that religious belief is a mind
virus that effectively these belief
structures are parasitizing human beings
and they are wasting the time and effort
that those human beings are spending on
that endeavor rather than the more
reasonable interpretation which is that
these belief systems have flourished
because they have facilitated the
interests of the creatures involved our
belief systems are built around
evolutionary success and they certainly
contain human benevolence which is
appropriate to phases of history when
there is abundance and people can afford
to be good to each other the problem is
if you have grown up in a period in
which abundance has been the standard
state you don't anticipate the way
people change in the face of austerity
and so what we are currently seeing is
messages that we have all agreed are
unacceptable re-emerging because the
signals that we have reached the the end
of the boom times those signals are
everywhere and so people are triggered
to move into a phase that they don't
even know that they have despite the
fact that human beings think that they
have escaped the evolutionary paradigm
they've done nothing of the kind and so
we should expect the belief systems that
people hold to mirror the evolutionary
interest that people have rather than to
match our our best instincts when we are
capable of being good to each other
because there's abundance we have those
instincts and so it's not incorrect to
say that human beings are capable of
being marvelous creatures and being
quite ethical and I would argue there's
a simple way of reconciling the correct
understanding that religious belief
often describes truths that in many
cases fly in the face of
we can understand scientifically with
the idea that these beliefs are adaptive
I call it the state of being literally
false and metaphorically true a belief
is literally false and metaphorically
true if it is not factual
but if behaving as if it were factual
results in an enhancement of one's
fitness to take an example if one
behaves in let's say the Christian
tradition in such a way as to gain
access to heaven one will not actually
find themselves at the pearly gates
being welcomed in but one does tend to
place their descendants in a good
position with respect to the community
that those descendants continue to live
in so if we were to think evolutionarily
the person who is behaving so as to get
into heaven has genetic interests those
genetic interests are represented in the
narrow sense by their immediate
descendants and close relatives in the
larger sense they may be represented by
the entire population of people from
whom that individual came and by acting
so as to get into heaven the fitness of
that person the number of copies of
those genes that continued to flourish
in the aftermath of that person's death
will go up so the belief in heaven is
literally false there is no such place
but it is metaphorically true in the
sense that it results in an increase in
fitness
[Music]